♪
STEVE: WELCOME BACK, I DON’T
KNOW WHAT IS WORSE, THE
STUPIDITY AND AUTHORITARIANISM
OF THE LOCKDOWN OR THE SICKENING
HYPOCRISY OF THE DEMOCRAT
LOCKDOWN LEADERS WHO BREAK THEIR
OWN RULES.
PELOSI, AND THE HAIR SALON,
FEINSTEIN AND THE PRIVATE
AIRPORT WITHOUT A MASK AND
LIGHTFOOT IN THE CROWD AND THE
HAIR SALON AND THEN THE BIG ONE
GAVIN NEWSOM, NO LARGE
GATHERINGS, STAY OUTDOORS,
SOCIAL DISTANCING, WEAR A MASK
BETWEEN BITES UNLESS OF COURSE
YOU MAKE THOSE RULES IN WHICH
CASE YOU CAN BREAK EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEM AS HE DID IN THAT
NOTORIOUS FRENCH LAUNDRY DINNER.
LISA, I THINK THERE’S A REALLY
GOOD REASON WHY THIS HAS REALLY
JUST, GOT EVERYONE AND RAGED,
NOT JUST HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE I LIVE BUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AT SUCH A SYMBOL OF THE
FACT THAT IF THEY REALLY
BELIEVED THAT ALL THE THINGS
THEY ARE SAYING WERE IMPORTANT
TO PUBLIC HEALTH THEY WOULD NOT
BREAK THEIR OWN RULES BUT THEY
WOULD BREAK THEIR OWN RULES
WHICH UNDERMINES EVERYTHING THEY
ARE SAYING.
>> EXACTLY.
SO WHY SHOULD CALIFORNIANS
FOLLOW THE RULES IF THEIR
GOVERNOR DOES NOT?
WHY SHOULD THEY BELIEVE THE
RULES ARE SCIENCE -BASED REASON
IF THE GOVERNOR DOES NOT.
I THINK WHAT IT REALLY DOES IS
EPITOMIZES WHAT THE RULING CLASS
ACTUALLY THINKS OF THEIR
CITIZENS.
THEY THINK NOTHING OF THEM.
IF GAVIN NEWSOM THINKS IT’S FINE
FOR HIS KIDS TO GO TO PRIVATE
SCHOOL WHILE PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE
SHUT DOWN AND THOSE KIDS ARE
FALLING FURTHER BEHIND BUT HIS
KIDS ARE ENTITLED TO GETTING A
BETTER EDUCATION AND NOT FALLING
BEHIND OR LOOK AT LIGHTFOOT
GOING AND GETTING HER HAIRCUT
WHILE BARBERSHOPS AND SALONS
WERE CLOSED WHILE PEOPLE CANNOT
FEED THEIR KIDS AND CANNOT OPEN
UP AND CUT HAIR OR MAKE A LIVING
AND IT’S THE SAME THING TO BE
SAID FOR THE PHILADELPHIA MAYOR
GOING OUT EATING INDOORS IN
MARYLAND WHILE INDOOR
RESTAURANTS WERE CLOSED AT THE
TIME IN PHILADELPHIA.
IT’S JUST DESPICABLE AND A
REFLECTION OF HOW THEY ACTUALLY
VIEW THEIR CITIZENS WHICH IS
VERY LITTLE BECAUSE WHILE THEY
ARE STRUGGLING OR WHAT FAMILIES
CAN’T GO AND SEE OR CAN’T SING A
BITE TO LOVED ONES OR CAN’T
HONOR AN INDIVIDUAL’S LIFE AT A
FUNERAL THEY ARE GOING AND
BREAKING THE RULES.
IT’S DISGUSTING, TO BE HONEST.
IT’S OUTRAGEOUS.
STEVE: I TOTALLY FEEL YOU, LISA.
WORDS ARE NOT ENOUGH TO EXPRESS
HOW ANGRY WE ALL FEEL.
CHARLIE, IT SEEMS TO BE WATCHING
THE RESPONSE AND THE POLITICIANS
RESPONSE BECAUSE THE WAY PELOSI
BLAMED THE SALON LIKE OF COURSE
I NEED TO GET MY HAIR DONE OR
WHATEVER BUT TO BE FAIR AT LEAST
GAVIN NEWSOM ELYSE APOLOGIZE FOR
THE WAY HE DID IT IT SEEMS TO BE
SOME KIND OF MINOR GAFFE WE MAKE
MISTAKES AND SLIGHT SCREW UP IN
A POLITICAL BUT WE MOVE ON BUT
IT’S MUCH DEEPER THAN THAT AND I
THINK THEY JUST HAVE NO IDEA HOW
THIS TOTALLY DESTROYS PEOPLE’S
FAITH, NOT JUST IN THEM
PERSONALLY BUT IN GOVERNMENT AND
THIS WHOLE MANTRA OF LISTENING
TO THE EXPERTS AND THIS IS A
REALLY DEEP THING BE EXPOSED
HERE.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
I’M WAITING FOR THEM TO CARE.
IT’S HALF APOLOGIES ARE BLAMING
RESTAURANTS AND GATHERINGS AND
BLAMING HER SALONS BUT IF I
CANNOT AFFECT A MORE STEREO
TYPICAL PLACE FOR GAVIN NEWSOM
TO BREAK THESE CODES OF THE
ISSUED THAT FRENCH LAUNDRY IN
NAPA VALLEY, ANYONE WHO IS BEEN
IN NAPA VALLEY AND KNOWS WHAT
I’M TALKING ABOUT.
IT WILL MOST EXPENSIVE RULING
CLASS WAITING FOR MONT TO GET A
RESERVATION RESTAURANTS IN THE
COUNTRY BUT IT ALSO REVEALS A
DEEPER POINT ABOUT THE LEFT.
EVERY POSITION THAT THEY
PUBLICLY ADVANCE THEY
CONTRADICT, WHETHER IT BE IN
FIREARMS AND THEY SAY THEY WANT
TO CONFISCATE GUNS BUT THEY WALK
AROUND WITH BORDER GUARDS.
POLICE THEY DON’T LIKE THE
POLICE EXCEPT HAVING THE POLICE
COME TO THEIR COMMUNITIES WHEN
THEY NEED THEM OR IN SCHOOLS AND
EDUCATION THEY SAY THEY DON’T
LIKE PRIVATE SCHOOLS OR CHARTER
SCHOOLS BUT THEY SEND THEIR KIDS
AND THE SAME WITH THESE VIRUS
LOCKDOWNS AND THEY SAY YOU MUST
STAY AT HOME, SHELTER IN PLACE
UNLESS YOU ARE THE DIVINE RIGHT
OF KING OF GAVIN NEWSOM WHO RUNS
CALIFORNIA THEN YOU CAN GO TO
FRENCH LAUNDRY AND NOT LIVE
UNDER THE RULES YOU MAKE OTHERS
BE ONE WHERE IS THIS GOING,
MATT?
IS THERE ANYWAY PEOPLE TO FIGHT
BACK?
I HATE PEOPLE TO -- WHAT YOU
THINK?
>> MOVE TO FLORIDA.
WE BELIEVE IN FREEDOM THERE.
THE FACT THAT CHARLIE KIRK KNOWS
MUCH ABOUT FRENCH LAUNDRY SHOWS
HOW MUCH MORE CULTURE KEY IS
THAT I AM.
I THOUGHT GAVIN NEWSOM WAS GOING
TO DO THE LAUNDRY WHEN I FIRST
SAW THE NEWS REPORTS BUT I HAVE
A CONFESSION TO MAKE TO YOU,
STEVE.
I TOO HAVE VIOLATED THE
WASHINGTON DC LOCKDOWNS WHEN I
GOT A HAIRCUT AND SO I’VE GOT NO
BLAME FOR SPEAKER PELOSI OR
ANYONE ELSE THAT FEELS THE NEED
TO DO THEIR HAIR BUT IT FELT
LIKE A DRUG DEAL.
WE HAD TO MEET AND AN
UNDISCLOSED LOCATION AND OPERATE
ONLY IN CASH AND NOT LOOK AT
EACH OTHER IN THE EYES DURING
THIS HAIRCUT TRANSACTION BUT I’M
SURE THE FACT OF ADMITTED THIS
NOW MEANS A SPECIAL COUNSEL WILL
LIKELY BE APPOINTED THERE WILL
BE A SERIES OF ETHICS
INVESTIGATIONS BUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ME AND CLOSE
YOU NEWSOM IS I’M NOT SORRY.
I THINK THE DANGER ISN’T IN A
MASK LIST GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA
BUT THE DANGER COMES WITH THESE
LOCKDOWNS TO PUNISH BLUE-COLLAR
PEOPLE AND PUNISH FOLKS WHO
DON’T HAVE THE ABILITY TO JUST
WORK FROM HOME AND THEY ARE
DEEPLY UNFAIR TO OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS WE SHOULD STAND AGAIN.
STEVE: EXACTLY.
YOUR PRO HAIRCUT,.
>> ALWAYS.
PRO HAIRCUT, I’M FOR IT.
STEVE: PRO- FREEDOM AND THEN
PEOPLE COULD TAKE RESPONSE
ABILITY.
>> HE THOUGHT GAVIN NEWSOM WAS
DOING THE FRENCH LAUNDRY.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE: I THINK WE WILL HAVE TO